die dritte welt von europa liegt am
stadtrand von plowdiw bulgarien
zweitgrößter stadt
wer im stadtteil story kino wo wohnt
gehört zu den ärmsten der gesellschaft
mehr als 50.000 menschen drängen sich in
den beton slum und kämpfen täglich ums
überleben
90 prozent arbeitslosigkeit kriminalität
und berge voller müll und unrat ist oli
p niveau so heißt es bei den bulgaren
ist die hölle auf erden ein vergessener
ort um den sich keiner kümmert
wer kann der flüchtet wer bleibt
vegetiert weiter im elend europas
größtes roma viertel können wir nur in
begleitung eines einheimischen betreten
remzi ist hier geboren wohnt aber seit
zehn jahren in dortmund die meisten
seiner landsleute wollen ebenfalls weg
keine arbeit kein garnichts leute
verdienen ja so was weißt du musst dann
möchten sie alle nach deutschland was
hingegen hat dortmund aber nach
deutschland obermeister drehen wollte
leute bisschen geld verdienen von
familie erschienen
das viertel nennt sich dortmund den
tausender sind aus dem elend ins
ruhrgebiet gezogen
arbeiten dort oder beziehen
sozialleistung ein teil des geldes
ernährt im slum ganze familie
wir treffen rahman auch er arbeitet und
lebt in deutschland und wir ziehen alles
dahin nachdoppeln
da haben die alles besser geld
deutschland sich besser
du hast deutschland 15 punkte in der
schule da schon mehr geld als hier
klicken sie auch viel geld wir schicken
auch geld zb du vergisst 1500 geschicks
zum beispiel 500 hier hilft da schon
mehr geld doch jeder tag hier ist ein
kampf ums überleben
vater branco und sein sohn ramadan
die beiden suchen im müll nach
essensresten die sie später auf dem
markt verkaufen wollen mitnehmen um rat
ein verwesender schaafs kadaver
nur meter entfernt greift der vater für
seinen sohn nach etwas essbarem
wir haben kein geld wir müssen unser
essen und trinken im müll suchen
schauen sie doch gesammelt dass da auf
und echtes wir haben seit 20 11 genießen
die bulgaren reisefreiheit
seit dieser zeit haben sich tausende in
einer art armut track von plowdiw aus
auf dem weg in den reichen westen
gebracht
auch ramsi flüchtete aus dem slum
arbeitet jetzt in dortmund auf dem bau
sogar scheiße nochmal man sie werden ab
dem das gibt es gibt gar nichts
ja wir viel zum beispiel ich glaub ich
hab ja dass pro kinder 180 euro sowie
fast noch besser geht nasko angelo steht
mit seiner frau und den sechs kindern
schon in den startlöchern auf dem weg
nach deutschland
die familie hat kein einkommen und wird
mit knapp 250 euro kindergeld und
sozialhilfe vom bulgarischen staat
unterstützt zu wenig zum überleben
200 euro fielen vater geht noch für die
busfahrt nach dortmund konkrete pläne
für die neue heimat hat er jetzt schon
wir wollen auf jeden fall nach
deutschland
ich weiß dass es bei sechs kindern
kindergeld jeden würde ich will auch
arbeiten
ich werde garantiert dort einen job
finden für viele ist die verzweiflung
hat so groß dass sie sagen gäbe gehen
nach deutschland
sie besorgen sich dann papiere woher
will er jetzt nicht sagen er hat nur
gesagt
es gibt leute hier im viertel die sagen
ihr könnt nach deutschland gehen dort
bekommt der kindergeld und das ist für
diese familien wenn sie sechs sieben
acht kinder haben ein vermögen wenn sie
dann 8 900 euro gekommen
wer nach deutschland will braucht
papiere anträge für mögliche
sozialleistungen übersetzung von
dokumenten in diesem kiosk am rande des
ghettos gibt es so gut wie alles was man
für einen start in deutschland benötigt
zahl der kunden wächst von tag zu tag
statt hielt wir auch wie in deutschland
job zu machen habe ich hab hier nur
arbeitslosengeld für deutschland geht
hier auch um kindergeld auch alles also
sie können hier auch kindergeld
beantragen oder normalerweise die machen
nur das papier schreiben warum viele
leute hier keine ahnung zu schreiben und
lesen
seit zehn jahren betreibt der ex-boxer
josef den diesen service für seine
landsleute bei den slum verlassen will
kommt zu ihm
wir haben kontakt auf der ganzen welt
alle suchen uns auf denn wir bieten so
ziemlich alles an
so sind wir zu einem einmaligen
unternehmen geworden
mit anderen worten wir bieten alle arten
von dienstleistungen an
man kann bei uns auch zahlungen
vornehmen auch stellen wie flug und
bustickets für das ausland aus dortmund
nordstadt 2100 kilometer nordwestlich
von plowdiw 55.000 menschen leben in
diesem stadtteil 45 prozent haben einen
ausländischen pass die nordstadt gilt
seit jahren als multi problem führte
mehr als 6000 armutsflüchtlinge aus
rumänien und bulgarien leben hier
der großteil erhält sozialleistungen
oder kindergeld wer wo oder wann ein
oder rausreißt ist kaum noch
nachzuvollziehen
in der nordstadt
gehen wir davon aus sind ungefähr über
170 nationen auf engem raum zusammen
es gibt dort verschiedene themen die
dort an gelandet sind auch das thema der
zuwanderung aus südosteuropa ist ein
thema in der nordstadt auch seit einigen
jahren und das hat politische
auswirkungen
mittlerweile konnte die polizei durch
eine null-toleranz-strategie verstärkte
streifen und gezielte schwerpunkt
einsätze die kriminalitätsrate in der
nordstadt drastisch senken
dennoch ist sie im vergleich zu anderen
stadtteilen immer noch hoch du liegst 60
können sich dann doch nicht alles
angriffen anwesens kernthema ist die
tonqualität und alles was man zusammen
hängt angefangen von dem pro verkaufter
der straße die bandenstrukturen diese
gibt die beschaffungs qualität damit
zusammen hängt also dieser aus
kraftfahrzeugen einbrüche und ähnliche
diebstähle
da sind neben aldi delikte wir haben
sofort das komplette strafgesetzbuch was
man hier auch erleben kann
der ständige zu- und wegzüge gerade von
familien aus europa steht die
ordnungshüter vor probleme
auch ein nachfassen von möglicherweise
straffällig gewordenen personen ist
daher kaum möglich anhand der
briefkasten ist jedenfalls nicht
auszumachen wer hier wohnt
probleme aus der stadt hat dabei zehn
menschen werden dann werden sich an
versuchen sozialleistungen zu empfangen
kindergeld verschwinden dann wieder wenn
sich aber nicht ab so dass manchmal auch
deswegen hat den menschen abgewendet
werden immer so ein bisschen
vernünftigen und datenstand
hinzubekommen und mit also nie
nachvollziehen können wie viel genau die
menschen hier sind und wir auch genau
ist vor einem café treffen wir eine
gruppe bulgaren die männer kommen
ebenfalls aus plowdiw und pendeln
regelmäßig nach dortmund offenbar sind
einige von ihnen hier gemeldet auch sie
genießen die vorteile deutscher
sozialleistungen 180 noch nicht wir
treffen eine familie die vor acht jahren
von plowdiw in die nordstadt gezogen ist
der älteste sohn jack i20 lebt mit den
eltern und seinen beiden geschwistern
auf 60 quadratmetern jackie hat koch
gelernt ist aber arbeitslos seine mutter
ist krank der vater ist ebenfalls ohne
job die wohnung wird vom staat bezahlt
mit kinder und arbeitslosengeld kommt
die familie auf 1500 euro im monat
zurück nach bulgarien will jacki auf
keinen fall pro person also kinder pro
monat was weiß ich sieben euro oder 8
euro nur noch kindergeld und also vom
staat also warum ag bekommt man so fast
15 euro also insgesamt bekommt noch eine
familie wenn man drei vier kinder sagen
wir mal 100 euro
ganz also hier ist eigentlich guten hat
pro person kriegt man hier fast 200 euro
+ arge und so weiter 300 400 euro
könnten und mit einem kinder nach wenn
man drei vier kinder hat oder zwei
kriegt man fast 700 800 euro und das
mittel wird hier gezeigt strom die ist
das also für mich ist deutschland das
beste land und freiheit